schützt eine normale erkältung vor
corona ja das hört sich erst mal ein
bisschen absurd an könnte aber
tatsächlich wahr sein biologen vermuten
dass nämlich schon länger der grund
dafür die typische erkältung wird auch
durch corona viren ausgelöst und dadurch
könnte eben ein gewisser schutz vor dem
neuartigen corona virus entstehen das
nennt man dann kreuzimmunität eine
studie des universitätsklinikums charité
und des max planck instituts zeigt jetzt
dass an dieser vermutung tatsächlich
etwas dran sein könnte
und genau über diese studie möchte ich
jetzt sprechen mit doktor martin stürmer
hallo herr stürmer ich grüße sie
für wie plausibel halten sie denn jetzt
die studie ja es gab ja schon mal
anzeichen dass das was dran sein könnte
das durch ein bauherr abgelaufene
erkältungs erkrankung mit unseren
bekannten coronaviren man alle gewissen
schutz hat also spricht der verlauf ist
etwas müde ich halte das schon für für
nachvollziehbar
die daten sprechen sind sind sie relativ
sauber erhoben
und ja es macht für mich schon sinn und
das auch weiter zu verfolgen und da
weitere studien darauf aufbauen zu
lassen
kann es denn sein dass menschen immun
sind obwohl sie gar keine antikörper
haben ja auch das ist möglich in einer
gewissen form muss sich das wie folgt
vorstellen wenn ich mich mit einem virus
infizieren oder man erreger dann ist man
immunsystem hat die aufgabe dieser
infektion zu erledigen das tut sie in
dem antikörper gebildet werden
aber es gibt auch einen zweiten arm des
immunsystems das ebenso wie hatte der
killerzellen generiert werden die
infizierte zellen abtöten das heißt kopf
erkennt in dieser zelle steckt ein virus
weg damit und diese beiden arme sind
aktiv und selbst wenn ich im blut keine
antikörper mehr da habe wird unser
immunsystem in der lage sein bei einer
neuinfektion zu reagieren und was genau
sie uns gerade angesprochen ist der
unterschied zwischen diesen t zellen und
antikörpern
wir sind wie gesagt zwei
unterschiedliche arme der antikörper
selber wenn ich den im blut sozusagen
schon vorher oder oder vorrätig habe
dann kommt der erreger an und es wird
sofort eliminiert weil diese
die körper docken an diesen erreger dran
bilden damit im prinzip so ketten und
blockieren wichtige funktionen dieses
erregers so dass da gar nicht erst in
die zelle rhein kann und gar keine
infektion stattfinden kann
die t zellen die arbeiten ein schritt
später die zelle ist schon infiziert das
virus ist in die zelle gegangen und dann
räumt diese zelle auf und sorgt dafür
dass eben keine weitere verbreitung des
virus erzeugt erfolgen kann und was
bedeutet das jetzt für einen impfstoff
könnte es sein dass es einen bestehenden
impfstoff gibt er auch schon einen
gewissen schutz gegen das neuartige
coronaviren gibt also die impfstoffe die
jetzt aktuell mit hochdruck entwickelt
werden und getestet werden da sind ja
schon einige in der so genannten phase 3
also in der letzten klinischen zulassung
und der eine impfstoff aus england
dieser sogenannte oxford and stoff da
habt ihr den vorher gering studien
gezeigt dass er sowohl antikörper als
auch eben diese t zellen stimulieren
kann und das wäre natürlich ein gutes
signal dass wenn das sich das wirklich
in den großen studien bewahrheitet dass
wir hier einen sehr effektiven
zweigleisigen impfstoff hätten der uns
hoffentlich hilft wieder zur normalität
zurückzukehren
vielen dank doktor martin stürmer für
ihre einschätzung zu dieser studie